my breakups been a very difficult thing
um I don't even know if I fit through it
Nikki Bella is having a hard time saying
goodbye to her life with John Cena on
the season 4 premiere of total Bella's
Nikki traveled to Tampa Florida to clear
out the home she shared with John after
calling off their engagement last year
moving all my stuff out it's just it
makes a closure and I think that's the
hardest part
when you just you move out and you shut
that door and you give someone your keys
that just it shuts the door to your
heart to that love and to the memories
and that no new memories will be made
which is so hard to think about and
while Nikki got emotional talking about
the move
it seems that now the 35 year old WWE
star is single and ready to mingle
so Nikki you're single and dating right
yeah actually no I am dating your say
you're dating Nikki and her twin sister
brie stopped by live with Kelly and Ryan
where she dished on her love life and
her date with the Bachelorette
contestant Peter Krause you went out
with some kind of famous guys yeah one
was on The Bachelor right he why is
Peter he's it's been a just one day it's
so far
Nikki revealed it was her sister who
hooked her up with Peter and admitted
their first and only date was a few
months ago I want to go out again I mean
I totally would go out again especially
I want to try it without cameras because
wait there were cameras there
ten people staring up you know that
ruins everything everything yeah
fans got a sneak peek of the steamy date
in the season 4 trailer for total
Bella's I haven't kissed another guy in
nine years
but Peter isn't the only guy Nikki's
been linked to post split according to
multiple reports the reality star is
dating her former Dancing with the Stars
partner 36 year old Arden
well we spend a lot of time together and
they need a lot from us and so I'm
someone who when that happens I kind of
shut down but Artem knows how to break
through me and he's really like learned
how to like let my guard down and so I
he's like my Russian therapist it's
great Russian therapist I like the two
were paired together during the 25th
season of the hit show in 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
and in the total Bella's season 4
trailer Nikki is seen having dinner with
our demand getting on the back of his
motorcycle
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]